جانوس قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قوتها الجويه نفذت خلال الساعات هي
الماضيه 6 10 غره على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه وانظمتها الصاروخيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واضافت الهيئه ان قواتها
المدفعيه استهدفت نقاط تحكم من روسيا عده
ومحطه كي رادار وعاشرت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الى ان القوات الروسيه شنت
خلال اليوم الماضي غاره جويه على اهداف
المدنيه الاوكرانيه ونفذت اكثر من 95
هجوما براجمات الصواريخ في اكثر من جبهه
شرقيه وجنوبيه البلاد
المتابعه تنضمي الي من كيف مراسلات
الجزيره كاترين حنا يا مرحبا كاترين ابرز
التطورات الميدانيه وايضا الدبلوماسيه
التي شهدتها اوكرانيا
على اكثر من مقاطعه الاوكرانيه لاسيه في
الشرق والجنوب بيان هيئه الاركان الصباحيه
تحدث عن غارات وقصف مدفعيه استهدف بالامس
سنوات متفرقه في اقليم باس تحديدا في
دوناتس
والهانسك وكذلك في شرقا في الجنوب ايضا
خلصون
وميكولايزولوجيا وتحدث عن ان هذه الهجمات
واضطرابات استهدفت بشكل الاساسييا اهداف
المدنيه
التحتيه في سوليدار تحديدا هناك همم تاكيد
مستمر من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه على انها
همم ما زالت لم تفقد السيطره كامله على
هذه المنطقه تحدثت القوات الجويه بالامس
انها تمكنت من تدمير طائره هجوميه روسيه
في الجهه الشرقيه من منطقه سوليدار تتحدث
كذلك القوات الاوكرانيه عن انها همم تصد
باستمرار وتحبط وهجمات روسيه على تلك لقد
تاتي من مناطق متفرقه من الجهه الشرقيه
لاقليم دونباس هذا على الصعيد الميداني
محمد ولكن البارز انه بالتزامن مع استمرار
هذه المعارك لا سيما في الجبهه الشرقيه
هناك تطورات بارزه تتعلق بموضوع تسليح
اوكرانيا وتزويدها بمزيد من المعدات
العسكريه النوعيه وذلك بناء على طلبات
مكثفه وعملا دبلوماسيا حثيث تكثف بشكل
كبير في الايام الماضيه بالتزامن مع
احتزام المعارك شرقا اعلان هولندا بالامس
من واشنطن انها همم تنقل الى اوكرانيا
بطاريه باتريات لتعزيز تنسان الدفاع الجوي
الصاروخي هذا يؤكد مزيدا من الدعم
الاوروبي وكذلك الامريكي اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا باتت الان همم يعني همم امنت
انها ستحصل على ثلاث بطاريات بطاريات بعد
اعلان الامريكيين ذلك وكذلك الالمان هناك
تدريبات بدات ايضا للضباط الاوكرانيين في
الولايات المتحده والمانيا وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني محمد بالامس توقع ان تنتهي
تدريبات الضباط الاوكرانيين على استخدام
باتريوت بغضون 10 اسابيع قال ان
الامريكيين التزموا بانهاء هذه التدريبات
للضباط الاوكرانيين في غضون 10 اسابيع
لاسيما وان الضباط الذين يخضعون للتدريب
في الولايات المتحده والمانيا لم يبدا من
النقطه الصفر اذا انهم همم يعني من ذوي
الخبرات العسكريه المتطوره طبعا كل هذه
التطورات على صعيد دعم اوكرانيا عسكريه
ياتي بعد ان اعلنت بريطانيا ايضا زياده
هذا الدعم على صعيد الدبابات المستشار في
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه بولوجيات بالامس ذكر
ان هناك تحالف دبابات اوروبي دعما
لاوكرانيا ايضا قائد الجيش الاكراني التقى
بالامس في لقاء ان هو يعني الاول له مع نظ
الامريكي مارك ميلر في في بولندا سبق ل
بولندا ايضا ان اعلنت دعمها بمزيد من
الدبابات وكذلك ليطانيا ولاتفيا وغيرهم من
الدول كل ذلك يؤشر الى مكانه قد تحدثت عنه
السلطات الاوكرانيه محمد عن ان الاشهر
المقبله بحسب معلوماتها الاستخباراتيه
ستشهد مزيدا من المعارك العنيفه لاسيا وان
السلطات هنا تتحدث عن ان روسيا تستعد لحرب
واسعه النطاق وطويله الامد في اوكرانيا
حنا ربما اضيف فقط ما ننوه اليه في هذه
النشره وهو انه هولاندا كذلك قالت بانها
تنوي الانضمام الى برنامج
في اللقاء الذي كان بين رئيس وزراءها همم
امس في واشنطن الذي يجتمع مع الرئيس
الامريكي شكرا جزيلا كابتن حنا مراسلت
الجزيره كنت معي كيف